I do think when it comes to what you're
talking about like collapsing birth rate
a lot of people talk about it as it's
like this inherently bad thing but I
don't really think of it that way and
the reason why I don't think of it that
way is because having lots of children
isn't good if those children aren't
being raised right right if those
children's are in like bad economic
scenarios
um if you're just having a lot of
children to have a lot of children
you're not going to be able to have
enough time or money to give them the
attention and care that they need
um I think in a lot of Western countries
you see like a lower birth rate but in
return you see like a higher quality of
life for a lot of these children
compared to other places